der da vorne hat genießt der hat mit
sicherheit corona oder die krippe oder
eine banale erkältung kann man das
überhaupt unterscheiden und wenn ja
woran und wenn ich corona hatte bin ich
dann immer wieder erklären es jetzt in
diesem video
[Musik]
erkältungskrankheiten treten wen
wundert's vor allem in der kalten
jahreszeit auf das lässt immer noch
viele menschen glauben busse ligges
wetter die kälte allein könnte eine
erkältung verursachen das ist aber
quatsch wenn ich mich nackig bei minus
30 grad am nordpol aufs eis setzte dann
bekomme ich frostbeulen und sonst was
aber mit sicherheit keine erkältung denn
dazu braucht es irgendwelche erreger
fast immer viren und wo keine anderen
lebewesen sind die diese viren haben und
bei denen ich mich dann eben mit diesen
viren anstecken könnte gibt es auch
keine infektion keine erkältung die
kälte spielt nur insofern eine rolle als
dass sich die meisten erkältungsviren
bei niedrigen temperaturen wohler fühlen
und länger überleben
außerdem sind bei kälte unsere
schleimhäute schlechter durchblutet die
viren können leichter eindringen
das neue corona virus mag es auch lieber
kalt es tritt vermehrt in der typischen
erkältungszeit haus zusammen mit den
anderen schnupfen husten heiserkeit
führen und der echten grippe der
influenza
aber woher weiß ich jetzt was ich habe
die unterscheidung erkältung oder echte
grippe ist da noch relativ einfach
ich werde immer wieder gefragt woher
weiß ich denn dass ich eine echte grippe
habt und zum arzt muss antwort wenn sie
es für möglich halten mit ihren
symptomen noch zum arzt zu gehen haben
sie ziemlich wahrscheinlich keine krippe
die kommt nämlich fast immer ganz
plötzlich innerhalb von wenigen stunden
ziemlich heftig eben haben sie sich noch
fit gefühlt jetzt haben sie fieber
richtig hoch schüttelfrost und wollen
nur noch eins ins bett eine typische
erkältung kündigt sich meistens an
es beginnt vielleicht mit kopfschmerzen
dann tun die muskeln und die knochen wie
jedenfalls empfindet man es so man fühlt
sich abgeschlagen die nase läuft oder
ist verstopft vielleicht kratzt es auch
schon im hals und all das zieht sich
über tage hin
die unterscheidung zu corona bzw cupid
19 ist dann schon schwieriger
bei kronau ihnen einige symptome der
grippe
andere wiederum lassen dann eine
eltern denken ein plötzlicher beginn
spricht aber deutlich mehr für eine
krippe als für corona schnupfen lässt er
an eine erkältung denken der kommt bei
corona zwar auch vor er ist aber kein
typisches symptom
wenn also einer nist spricht dass er
gegen korona cupid 19 erkrankte haben in
der ersten woche sogar eher wenig
symptome nach dieser woche entscheidet
es sich dann welchen weg die infektion
nimmt in den meisten fällen heißt dass
weitere abschwächung der symptome in
wenigen anderen zügige verschlechterung
husten kann bei allen dreien also
erkältung grippe kroner auftreten das
hilft also nicht wirklich weiter aber es
gibt etwas relativ spezifisches balkon
und das ist der riecht und geschmacks
verlust davon berichten doch relativ
viele patienten und häufig ist diese
störung sogar das erste symptom vor
allen anderen riechen und schmecken
haben physiologisch viel miteinander zu
tun so dass die beeinträchtigung von
beidem nicht verwundert anders als bei
der erkältung oder hin und wieder bei
der krippe wo es aufgrund der
verstopften nase auf zuruf störungen
kommen kann tritt die geruchs und
geschmacks störungen bei corona sehr
plötzlich auf und hält auch länger an
das liegt daran dass die entsprechenden
sensoren dafür bestimmte zellen des
nervensystems vom virus zerstört werden
gott sei dank können sich diese neurone
wieder neu bilden das können andere
nervenzellen nicht so während der
neubildung kommt es aber dann zu
störungen in der wahrnehmung so dass wir
quasi falsch schmecken beziehungsweise
riechen das korrigiert sich mit der zeit
aber wieder kurzatmigkeit ist noch ein
symptom dass er für corona spricht
[Musik]
zusammengefasst kann man also sagen
plötzlicher heftiger beginn spricht eher
für eine echte grippe langsamer beginnen
mit schnupfen er für eine erkältung und
langsame beginn mit riesch und geschmack
störungen oft mit fieber und husten erst
recht mit kurzatmigkeit er für corona
was wieder allen drei infektionen gemein
ist man kann sich erneut infizieren von
erkältungsviren und der krippe kennen
wir das ja schon beim neuen corona virus
ist dass auch inzwischen nachgewiesen
ob das nur selten passiert oder eher die
regel ist weiß man noch nicht aber dafür
dass es überhaupt passiert gibt es
mindestens zwei gründe zum einen
verändern sich viren eigentlich ständig
und wenn sie sich stark genug verändert
haben erkennt unser immunsystem die dann
veränderten viren nicht mehr so richtig
es kommt zur infektion weil die beim
ersten mal gebildeten antikörper nicht
exakt zu den veränderten bieren passen
zum anderen vergisst unser immunsystem
aber nach einiger zeit anders als zb bei
masern die frühere infektion wieder die
immun gedächtniszellen die eigentlich
dazu da sind beim erneuten auftreten des
virus sofort ganz viele antikörper zu
bilden haben den bauplan für diese
antikörper irgendwie verlegt und dadurch
klappt das nicht so schnell mit der
produktion
man ist also nicht auf ewige zeiten
immun
micron spricht einiges dafür dass selbst
wenn ziemlich genau dasselbe virus nach
einiger zeit wieder anklopft eine
erneute infektion möglich ist allerdings
verläuft die zweite infektion allem
anschein nach dann oft milder
wie lange man nach der infektion immun
bleibt ob das jetzt wochen monate oder
jahre sind hängt von vielen faktoren ab
und ist noch nicht bekannt dasselbe wird
wohl auch für eine impfung gelten
vermutlich ist es bei krone ähnlich wie
bei der krippe auch hier hält die
immunität ja nicht sehr lange an weil
sich die krippe wir uns ständig etwas
ändern muss man jedes jahr mit einem
neuen angepassten impfstoff impfen wenn
man jetzt wissen will
ob man kroner schon hatte kann man
natürlich einen antikörpertest beim arzt
machen
aber erstens wissen wir jetzt dass das
auch bei vorhandenen antikörper nicht
heißt dass man sich nicht irgendwann
erneut anstecken kann und zweitens hat
sich in studien gezeigt dass andersrum
zwischen 30 und 40 prozent der ehemals
corona infizierten nach kurzer zeit gar
keine antikörper mehr aufweisen
ein negativer antikörpertest heißt also
nicht definitiv dass man noch kein
corona hatte es gibt nämlich in unserem
immunsystem nicht nur antikörper sondern
auch noch sogenannte t zellen die auch
spezifisch passend für das jeweilige
virus gebildet werden und auch
gedächtniszellen entwickeln
diese sogenannte zelluläre immunabwehr
scheint gerade bei krone eine wichtige
rolle zu spielen
sie wird aber mit den normalen test
nicht erfasst
[Musik]
die meisten menschen werden glaube ich
große schwierigkeiten haben das zu
unterscheiden ist das jetzt corona
krippe oder vielleicht doch nur eine
erkältung und ich bin auch sicher die
meisten ärzte haben schwierigkeiten
letztendlich kann man es ja auch nur mit
dem labortest sagen aber da wird es auch
bald tests geben die tatsächlich alles
testen können also zumindest
unterscheidung zwischen krippe und
zwischen corona so ganz wehrlos stehen
wir also nicht da ein bisschen dürfen
wir unserem immunsystem schon zutrauen
und wer weiß vielleicht verliert das
neue virus in einigen jahren seinen
schrecken und reits sich artig in die
lange schlange der üblichen
erkältungsviren 1
die chancen dafür stehen gar nicht so
schlecht
[Musik]